this is the first time this year that
the huang family has taken a vacation
and the place they chose to visit is the
city where the pandemics started
during a public holiday in october
called golden week
during the same time last year more than
seven million chinese travelers
went overseas this year tourist sites
around the world have been empty
and most chinese travelers are choosing
to stay in the country
so many are going to ground zero of the
pandemic
during golden week wuhan had the most
visitors of any chinese city
people are also flocking to the city to
see a thousand-year-old tower
and walk along china's longest river
wuhan is overcoming its pandemic past
to rise in the ranks of top travel
destinations
the first coronavirus case was detected
late last year at one of wuhan's largest
meat and seafood markets and authorities
moved swiftly to lock the city down
after 76 days the lockdown was lifted
and many people emerged from their homes
for the first time
but a fresh outbreak of cases about a
month later forced authorities to roll
out a mass testing plan for the city's
11 million people
they achieved it in about 10 days since
then the city hasn't reported any
locally transmitted cases
[Music]
a safe city is a critical part of the
wuhan government's plan to help boost
tourism
authorities have put in place specific
health requirements to ensure the city
remains covid free
like at wuhan's main amusement park
all staff at happy valley are required
to test for coronavirus
and the park has had to limit capacity
to 75 percent
tian zhao has been working at happy
valley for nine years
and when the park reopened after the
city's nearly three-month lockdown
she was assigned to a new role
in before entering the park
visitors also have to register online
and submit their national id numbers in
order to facilitate contact tracing in
case of an outbreak
it also helps that everyone in china is
part of a health code system
that tracks coronavirus infection and
travel histories
a safe city means that people like huang
will travel more than 200 miles to visit
and spend money here
huang hena's family spent about 300
dollars during their two-day stay in
wuhan
is central china's main transit hub and
during the early days of the pandemic
its airport and railways helped spread
the virus
but now those same transportation links
are bringing in visitors
during golden week wuhan received more
than 18 million tourists
[Music]
but spending still hasn't come back to
normal levels
the long holiday generated about 1.4
billion dollars of tourism revenue for
the city
that's down about 30 from the same
period last year
and he's been running this far in the
city center for more than seven years
during the lockdown in january juan's
bar like all businesses had to shut down
the bar reopened in mid-april to a slow
trickle of local customers
but juan says he noticed a sharp change
after the city's mass testing effort was
completed